technology democratizes consumption and
consolidates production which means if
you're the best in the world you get to
do it for everyone education is going to
become or already has been and will
increase in its fragmentation so you'll
have more niche verticals and instead of
having generalists which is what formal
education is based on liberal arts where
you get like i've got english and math
and female studies and whatever right
instead it's how to use aaron b to make
money
how to drive uber and make money how to
do amazon fba there's more amazon
sellers than there are almost pick a
profession that's out there in the
united states and there are more
individual amazon sellers than there are
almost of any subgroup of individual
thing but why isn't amazon or e-commerce
a major in undergraduate it's a real way
of making money so i think that with
this huge fragmentation education hasn't
hasn't gotten close to catching up but
the demand for high value skills has
never been higher and so you have this
huge amount of demand for people who
want to have skills so they can feed
themselves and provide value and then
you have almost no supply